how did the opportunity to be on
Celebrity Big Brother come to you my
agent coffee really okay yes he was just
like would you want to do this and I was
like I guess I mean the reason why is
because like I've never done like a
competition yeah any type of show like
that and I always thought it would be
fun to do
I hadn't really watched Celebrity Big
Brother I didn't really know what I was
getting myself into
so I called my daughter Riley yeah cuz
she watches yeah and I was like okay
tell me the truth is this something
that'll be cool for me to do and she was
like yeah you should do it it'll be fun
like okay but she can't come in the
house with you so now what are you gonna
do have you done homework have you
watched not enough I've seen about three
episodes so far of the let the first
celebrity yeah I mean it's easy okay
yeah I do want to let you know you are a
our most unprepared celebrity you so far
are you serious yes people have hired
therapists and you I mean on body
language
yeah yes that's one too many seasons
worth a big so you're the moat you're
just gonna fly by the seat of your SAS
yeah well I feel like that works with me
a lot you try when you overthink things
sometimes it's like you're doing too
much and I definitely don't want to be
one of those people that is just like
way over the top doing too much to where
you like yeah you know well we don't
know cuz you've only watched three
episodes so yeah
are you nervous being confined in a
house with other celebrities hell yeah
you are
okay this is what I compared to okay The
Real Housewives of Atlanta yeah I am I
mind I'm like if I was stuck in a house
with them yes but a month yeah I would
go crazy
yes so I've just said okay everything
that you would normally do bring that
back down about 30% okay I was gonna say
90% you said drain it to 90 percent down
90 percent to a 10 you think weird so
it's in you know it's my life is
craziest housewives while we is Angeles
okay so here's the thing out of the
first couple of episodes that I saw the
last one I said okay you don't want to
be too bossy huh because that doesn't
work huh but then you can't let people
run you over either because then that's
when they think that they're
manipulating you to do what they want
you to do that's not gonna work here No
so I've thought of a couple of things
they may help me okay okay so I can cook
okay okay I'm pretty good cook so I
figured okay if I cook for them yeah I
don't make friends that way I figure if
I clean up you know cuz everybody's not
gonna clean but I'm not doing both so
that's what they got to figure out if
you want me to cook I'll cook if you
want me cleanup I'll clean up but I'm
not gonna be cooking and cleaning thank
you okay so you got to figure that out
what is your biggest fear entering the
house is it being away from your friends
and family no cell phone no TV no music
my biggest fear is going home first oh
because my family said they're gonna
disown me okay good luck so okay the
biggest fear okay the second thing is
like I'm already going crazy without my
phone because I'm a social media addict
so I'm like for everybody who follows me
on social media normally they know I
normally post a lot but for the last few
days they haven't really posted much so
they know now yeah yeah I guess well we
know the world knows who's in the house
and that's what that's what else drives
me crazy is that the whole you know and
I don't know so in my mind these are the
things that I'm wondering are there
gonna be people in the house that I know
and don't I I cannot tell you if I get
over here I'm telling you what I think
okay in my head if I do know them will
we get along are these people that I
know that we are good or that I know
that we aren't good Oh
cuz there could be a problem I
definitely think there's gonna be some
firecrackers this season for you oh I'm
extremely competitive uh-huh
but I'm gonna try to dial it back yes
because I have noticed if they think
you're a threat yeah you're out you're
out of there so I'm not gonna play down
lay down lay down at least for the first
three weeks yeah yeah a few stars had
such a hard time on the first season of
Celebrity Big Brother that they actually
sent themselves home they're like I'm
out is
there anyway where you would be like I'm
out I gotta go I'm gonna try to be tough
and stick through it nothing I will
admit that I do miss my children and my
husband already yeah
but they are supporting me in this okay
so I know they will be okay now knowing
the amount of prep you did I think I
know the answer to this next question
but did you reach out to any one from
season one of Celebrity Big Brother for
advice well I did Oh
Pratt was just a little okay tell me
brandy mm-hmm she you know she gave me a
little bit of advice what was the advice
well the first thing she said it was
horrible
yeah you're not gonna make it okay but
she said well if you just you know you
have decided that you're definitely
doing this she said find the most
athletic person in the house and be
friends with them oh that's great advice
that's what she said ah who could that
be
let's all think this'n your fancy lady
the food situation inside you said your
cook it can be difficult are you
prepared to eat slop wait what
sometimes I know they had food and we
just couldn't do their I mean there's
food yes but like sometimes when you
lose you only get to eat slop what a
slob it's just like a mix one time one
season someone just ate ham
yeah like oatmeal kind of like sloppy
food one person got a like a large
amount of ham just ham every day all ham
that was it yeah I don't slap on my
plate I don't know what to do about this
I didn't know that part you taught me
something now what are you going to do
with the prize money 250 buckaroos
thousand buckaroos okay I like that a
business lady what is your strategy for
winning Celebrity Big Brother okay
obviously I didn't have a huge plan or
plot but the one thing that I thought
about was I always want to be in within
the large groups of people so if the
rooms are like four people in this room
- I always want to be in the bigger room
because that's more people that you can
make a bond
with make a relationship with and I'm
gonna do my best to not allow too many
people to have conversations with me and
not in the room so say for instance if I
see people kind of breaking off okay
girl would you do another that so she
can't be over there plotting against me
and talking about me when I'm not around
are you sure about this why the more
people don't fool with the list but
you're gonna be cool but you're gonna
meet in the middle of all the drama
you're gonna have to keep the gossip
straight because if you're an adult
gossip what I'm saying is keep friendly
relationships so like say for instance
what I noticed on the first delivery
when you have all those people in one
room normally they bond together and so
they're not gonna vote each other off
mm-hm
so I want more people uh-huh will feel
bad about kicking me off mm-hmm then
just like one person a deeply appreciate
their like I'm not gonna win every
challenge I'm gonna cook and hope that
people don't vote me off the problem is
if you win too many challenges your
people want to get rid of you right so
listen when you go on shows like this
this dance start survive or whatever
sometimes they can really boost your
fame I mean you're already on a massive
franchise and have all this stuff going
on but will you what are your hopes and
dreams for the rest of the world who
might not know who you are when you find
all these new fans what do you want well
I mean obviously you want you know it's
always good when more people are
supportive of you and everything that
you're working on so yeah I would love
more people to know about my view of my
business is my music that I write and
yeah and my charity kandi cares that
like I don't know I just feel like the
more people that you're able to touch
and reach yeah it's always a good thing
weathers just having good relationships
whatever it is okay well good luck
mm-hmm
[Music]